haribo macht kinderfroh und besteht aus
Tier oh no in den gummifrechen finden
sich nicht nur ein sondern zwei
tierische Produkte in der kleinen
Vegetarier ne aber bei sowas
könnte das fast passieren Sebastian
zeigt wie die frische hergestellt werden
und welche Tiere dafür herhalten müssen
[Musik]
für so süße kleine Gummifische
brauchen wir erstmal richtig viel
Kollagen und das lösen wir hier raus
also
rein damit und noch ein Öhrchen
ein bisschen Haut
Kollagen gewinnt die Industrie vor allem
aus schweinehalten unter anderem auch
aus Sehnen und Knorpeln für die maximale
Extraktion des Kollagens brauchen wir
Salzsäure die ist stark
ätzend
[Musik]
Sebastian lege lässt die schweinestücke
einwirken und erhitzt sie Säure und
Hitze verändern die Struktur des
Kollagens und lösen es heraus in der
Industrie kann das einige Tage dauern
aber
aus unlöslichem kollagen ist leicht
lösliche Gelatine geworden extrahiert
steckt sie in der Lösung Gelatine in
Reinform gewinnt die
Lebensmittelindustrie durch einen
komplexes Verfahren
der Lösung müssen zunächst die
unerwünschten Stoffe entzogen werden
Säurereste Fett und Salz zerstören die
Industrie setzt auf Filter und
Trennverfahren dann entzieht sie das
Wasser im vakuumverdampfer am Ende steht
reine Gelatine in Plattform oder als
feines Granulat
ich habe immer noch diesen Schweinestall
Geruch in der Nase und
riecht genauso ich bin ja kein
Vegetarier ne aber bei sowas könnte das
fast passieren für die quaxi frische
muss das Gelatine Pulver in Wasser
aufquellen und jetzt fangen wir mit dem
grünen vom Frösche an
so erhitzen Sebastian lege Wasser Zucker
Dextrose und Glukose
die Gelatine kommt erst danach dazu sie
ist temperaturempfindlich bei über 80
Grad verliert sie ihre gelierkraft
[Musik]
genau
dieser schweinige Ruch ne der geht ja
immer noch nicht von raus aber es kann
gleich nur besser werden jetzt können
wir das Aroma dazu geben komm gib mir
jetzt die Apfel Dröhnung bitte
Apfelaroma wird meist chemisch
hergestellt und schmeckt intensiv so
perfekt jetzt brauchen wir noch die
grüne Farbe Sebastian lege gibt blaues
Spirulina rotes Saflor und gelbes
Apfelsaftkonzentrat dazu
[Musik]
das sieht aus wie ein gekippter
Gartenteich fast wie beim Original
[Musik]
tut mir leid keiner Frosch ich muss
jetzt ein Loch im Bauch Bohren der
originalfrosch dient als Stempel
Sebastian lege drückt den immer wieder
in einen stärkebett so stellt er Formen
her die Lebensmittelindustrie setzt
einen ganz ähnliches Verfahren ein
[Musik]
meine sind aber aus wie ne ich habe die
irgendwie an meinem Body-Mass-Index
angepasst junge junge Junge sind das
fette Dinge
so
die können schon mal ganz entspannt
aushärten und jetzt kommt der weiße
Boden Haribo Frösche bestehen aus zwei
Schichten den weißen Boden stellt
Sebastian lege mit Maracuja und
Pfirsicharoma her
und jetzt machen wir daraus eine weiße
Schaummasse durch Gelatine wird die
Masse schaumig
so schnell macht man weiße Farbe
und jetzt kriegen die Frösche ihrem
Boden die grüne Schicht ist mittlerweile
hart Sebastian lege kann den weißen
Schaum auftragen
die müssen jetzt auch Aushärten damit
die später wunderschön glänzen und nicht
aneinander kleben brauche ich noch ein
weiteres tierisches Produkt und das
besorge ich mir jetzt
Haribo überzieht seine Frösche unter
anderem mit Bienenwachs Sebastian lege
besucht einen Imker im Rheinland der hat
seine Bienenstöcke mitten im Wald
aufgestellt hallo hallo Thomas
Inka Meister Thomas Rosenau hat 250
Bienenvölker mit jeweils bis zu 35.000
Bienen
hier unten ist die Party ne ja das
ungefähr so wie in so einem Berliner
Underground Club ne da sind unten im
Keller sind geht halt richtig ab wo
bekommen die Bienen ihr Wachs her ja
Bienen können Bienenwachs selber
produzieren tatsächlich die haben
Wachsdrüsen in ihrer Körper Unterseite
und schwitzen da wachsen aus nee damit
produzieren die dann hier dieses weiße
das fast durchsichtiger gewachsen was
wir hier sehen boah
die Bienen würden das normalerweise
jetzt verdeckeln hier um den Honig
haltbar zu machen für den Winter
auch die Farben stellen die Bienen her
ja und wie komme ich jetzt an meinen
Wachs war das brauche ich ja ja wir
haben jetzt hier eine Honigwabe die wir
tatsächlich gleich mit in ihrem Imkerei
nehmen und dort ganz normal die
Honigernte machen und dabei fällt jede
Menge Wachs an eben dieses
entdeckungswachs das entdeckungswachs
gibt es nur zu einer bestimmten Zeit
zwischen Mai und September oh
geriets aber auch schon schön so das ist
jetzt eine Wabe die wir heute entdecken
und schleudern wollen Thomas Rosenau
kratzt das entdeckungswachs von den
Waben ab Sebastian lege stampft es zu
einer festen Masse die geöffneten
Honigwaben spannt er in eine Schleuder
ein der Honig fließt ab das restliche
Honig Wachs Gemisch landet in einer
Maschine mit zwei rotierenden übrig
bleibt eine Zehe Masse ja dann würde ich
sagen machen was Wachs oder genau
[Musik]
den letzten Honig vom Wachs das dauert
vier bis fünf Stunden
[Musik]
so
das goldgelbes Bienenwachs von oben
sieht er noch schön sauber aus ja
bekommen meine kleinen Gummibärchen
jetzt ein sehr sehr charmanten Mantel
vielen Dank tschüss
und jetzt kommt das Frosch Finale diesem
wunderbar ausgehärtet und hier ist mein
Bienenwachs
Haribo überzieht seine Frische mit einer
Mischung aus Bienenwachs und
cannauberwachs Bienenwachs schmilzt ab
etwa 61 Grad der perfekte Überzug für
Sebastians Frösche damit sie in der Tüte
nicht zusammenkleben
[Musik]
mein kleiner Frosch man denkt immer so
ein Produkt kauft oh Süßigkeit stecken
aber zwei tierische Produkte drin guten
Appetit
[Musik]
schmecken echt komisch
Bienenwachs für die Oberfläche und
schlachtreste für die bissfeste
Konsistenz
warenindustrie setzt auf zahlreiche
Tierprodukte in Düsseldorf will
Sebastian lege herausfinden Wissen
Verbraucher das dazu hat er verschiedene
Süßigkeiten mitgebracht in jedem Produkt
steckt eine andere tierische Zutat
was meinst du was alle Produkte
miteinander gemeinsam haben in allen
Zucker drin
nein nein alle diese Produkte enthalten
tierische Produkte auch die Sümpfe ja
ich bin immer davon ausgegangen dass sie
vegan sind aber nein sind sie nicht
Sebastian löst auf
pass auf in einem dieser Produkte steckt
okay
Bienenwachs überzieht nicht nur die
haribo-schlümpfe sondern auch viele
andere Süßigkeiten Fruchtgummis Schoko
Nüsse und auch Smarties
dann ja klar Schweineknochen Gelatine
macht die Marshmallows fluffig und sorgt
in vielen anderen Süßigkeiten für eine
gummiartige Konsistenz
wisst ihr was das hier ist
ein Ast mit harzdorf
fast richtig
und irgendein Pilz das weiße
Leute
das sind die Experimente damit schließt
sie ihrem Brutkasten
das ist wie so eine Schutzschicht da
drunter sind ihre Eier sie stirbt aber
da drunter und ihre Eier können
schlüpfen das sieht richtig lecker aus
und macht richtig Appetit auf
egal wo es drin ist Schellack überzieht
Ovomaltine Rocks Schokobons oder Tic Tac
der Stoff sorgt für Glanz Härte und
schützt die Süßigkeiten
die Heimat der lackschildlaus liegt in
Asien Weibchen saugen Saft aus der
Würzpflanze und scheiden Harz wieder
raus dieses ausgeschiedene Harz wird
zweimal jährlich geerntet und
weiterverarbeitet zu Schellack
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so ein tierisches Erzeugnis andere Läuse
landen komplett in Süßigkeiten
dass die Koh Chemie Schildlaus die wird
gekocht getrocknet und dann wird der
Farbe drauf gemacht
mal vorstellt der tierische Zusatzstoff
steckt den M&Ms Kaugummis und
Fruchtgummis rote Süßigkeiten können auf
Läuse hindeuten nie Schildläuse werden
auf kaktusblättern gezüchtet richtige
Weibchen tragen viel rote Farbe in sich
getrocknet und gekocht werden sie zu
roten Pulver Kamin ich wusste das ja
nicht mal ich bin so vegetarisch und ein
bisschen interessierter
in denen ist alles davon ich habe letzte
Woche noch eine Packung davon gegessen
und ich habe groß gechillt ich werde
Vegetarier im
[Gelächter]
ein Problem für Vegetarier und Veganer
Kamin und Schellack sind aus tierischem
Ursprung das wird in der Zutatenliste
nicht deutlich Hersteller müssen bei
einigen Stoffen auch gar nicht angeben
ob sie tierische Herkunft sind
transparent ist das nicht
[Musik]